ene mene mai ich wünsche mir eine neue
folge wie schmeckt dabei exakt hallo
leute willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wie schmeckt und ja heute machen wir die
kirmes passt eben aus bibi blocksberg
und häufig eine ganze folge der nicht
raus zum allerersten mal etwas auf einem
das inoffizielle harry potter kochbuch
von mutter mir bist kyritzer reden mehr
als 150 magische rezepte zum nachkochen
hier ist das so klappt wie die kürbis
pasteten und ich muss sagen dass im
internet so viele verschiedene rezepte
gefunden habe aber ihr habt mir auch
unbedingt das buch empfohlen das ist da
auch noch das kochen soll deswegen
machen wir das einfach mal so viel wie
sie oder das buch fliegt weg frei für
den teig brauchen wir 150 gramm mehl 1
esslöffel zucker ein viertel teelöffel
seit wann gekühlte butter 140 gramm um
gehärtete pflanzen platt was auch immer
das heißt und 46 fleckl eiswasser aber
wo mit kürbis kosten natürlich mit einem
kürbis und zwar braucht mit 225 gramm
für das gerät da man darüber in
deutschland nicht so wirklich findet
müssen wir uns das selber macht dann
brauchen wir noch ein afrikaner für
gemeinden muss karten und 55 gramm
zucker und 1 80 teelöffel gemahlener
zünden vor wie mit den künsten anfangen
können müssen wir uns erstmal über
kurier machen aber das geht ganz eins
mit euch euren kürbis und teilten die
teile so einfach geht das dann mit ihrem
mittelschule und den kern auf ein
backblech und die große kugel ist aber
das ganze geschäft im internet also
schaut da einfach nach wissen was mir da
das hier gerade viel zu lange und wir
haben noch mal die am start also glaube
ich jetzt die kürbisse fertig
nun wieder ganz gut auch die haut könnt
ihr jetzt einfach so ab 10 kannst das
heißt lasst uns vorher noch mit dem
abkühlen und das ist jetzt eure heiße
kürbis matsche pampe und das was übrig
jetzt müsst ihr essen und da wird sich
dafür nicht ob ich für wirst du gerne
mag
hier haben wir 225 gramm heizens
kürbispüree das mit mir damals format
jetzt kommen 50 gramm zucker rein
ich verstehe mich genau wie man einen
achten teelöffel muskatnuss jetzt
abrechnungen sollten ist das ein achtel
war es so dass man es nicht übertreiben
darf weil mannheim
jetzt kommt noch ein achtel teelöffel
zimt erfahren wir das alles oder so
richtig gut
lenkrad und ein anderes probieren oh
mein gott dann schmecken die sache doch
hochmut machen wir jetzt den teig und
abnehmen wie eine rührschüssel packen
sogar ein und vermischen das gut mit dem
finger und da kommt jetzt hinzu unser
unten gehört russland im verzug ist und
jetzt genießen wir das noch macht spaß
aber es fehlte mal in welchem haus weit
ihr ich bin in krippendorf wie man
unschwer erkennen kann
ich hab ja noch nicht genug damit
angegeben ich habe mir das will porto
theaterstück in london angeschaut und
das kommt so cremig auch fake empire
verkackt habt macht einfach mehr mehr
auf und fertig ist jetzt fertig aber
weil er noch viel zu weiches gehörte
jetzt noch in den kühlschrank mit der
haft wird und man gut aus rollen kann
auch heute dafür geld man sich zaubern
kann
im mai teilt fertigkeit und hard facts
der teig muss jetzt ausgerollt werden
dafür nimmt er einfach ein bisschen mehl
auf eine arbeitsfläche dünn ausrollen es
auch nicht wird ist eigentlich nudelholz
liebe aber ich habe in den film noch nie
ein nudelholz gesehen oder freihandel
und frei schnauze mit dem glas schneidet
eine runde form auf auch die
begründetheit den kommt jetzt ein gebiss
die kürbiscremesuppe und das machen wir
dann sozusagen
wie das schweizer aus ich muss mal den
zeitgleich ihr tod hat jetzt hinten habe
steinmann ever müssen das zu kompliziert
kein upgrade machten einen bio 1
mitgebracht ich kann es nicht sagen ob
dieser tag irgendwie besser ist aber der
andere ist einfach die abbruch getan wir
hier unseren teig wer jetzt nicht so
komisch spricht die da vorbeikommt dann
machen wir den unterricht natürlich
nicht weil das eine gute idee war mit
dem ei machen wir zu und linda buck bild
davon machen wir jetzt alle fertig unter
den sessions gefiedert und das sind
jetzt ungefüllten pasteten ignoriert wie
in der mitte sieht nicht so gut aus aber
dafür gibt wie ganz gut gelungen ist nur
noch mit der gabel eine weitere
eingestochen und oben noch so drei
stückchen rein gemacht und die vermisste
13 backofen und dann werden wir schauen
was für geboren ist und in der zeit in
der die passierten im backofen sind
versuche ich mal auf dem restlichen teig
und ein kürbis much noch gleicht guckst
du das so zu machen
mal guckt ein ganz wichtiger tipp ich
werde nicht mit katzen spielen mit was
im ofen hat wohin die harry potter
vertreten aus und der kriegt alle die
wichtigste frage wie schmeckt süß
schmeckt sehr gut
ich habe den akku aufgeladen und kann
ganz in ruhe mit euch eine kürbis
portrait de probieren wie auch abgekühlt
ist
so wie sie ist okay geworden nur wird
sie von innen aus jetzt stellen muss
natürlich der allerwichtigste frage wie
schmeckt wie kürbis titel auf harry
potter supergeil und so sieht meine
kleine kürbis keks kreation aus also
verfestigten machen so viel übrig habt
könnt ihr das auch zusammenmischen
eigenen heiß ich hoffe euch das video
gefallen und wenn ja dann gibt meinen
daumen nach oben und schreiben die
kommentare rezeptvorschläge wie diese
folge fand st
bis dann